on my way to work guess what I just
found
hour hey how come out here Starbucks you
tell us to boycot them bro turn the
camera off my
we do you want to speak with confidence
like these amazing personalities every
single one of these amazing speakers
have taken the same program with brother
Muhammad Arad Muhammad Arad has helped
develop all of us it's extremely
beneficial to do this course definitely
recommend this
course to access the free lifechanging
training now hold on guys is that
Al I'm on my way to work guess what I
just
found B
hour
hey here Starbucks you tell us to
boycott them bro turn the camera off man
what you doing bro you tell them to
boycot Starbucks but you're drinking a
Starbucks all right bro let me tell you
bro are you mad you think's going to
drink from Starbucks I borrowed this cup
from them and I'm about to give you some
information boycotting brothers and
sisters is working despite what certain
individuals say Starbucks has lost 11
billion not million not 11,000 not
111,000 they've lost 11 billion pound
from the stock market shares now why are
we boycotting Starbucks alhamdulillah
even in Morocco the boycott is work so
much they are closing down their stores
brothers and sisters Howard Schultz is
the largest private owner of Starbucks
shares and it is a and he is a stch
Zionist bastard he's a bastard that's
what he is to invest heavily in Israel's
economy including a recent 1.7 billion
investment in cyber security startup
called whiz brothers and sisters what
you see here do you think we ever going
to drink from Starbucks never you know
why cuz the blood of the brothers and
sisters the Palestinian brothers and
sisters as you can see this is just to
symbolize that is in these cuffs that
you're drinking we see sometimes some
Muslims come to to the stores W there is
nothing that tastes better to me than
hitting the pockets of these son of a
bastards so if you are drinking from
Starbucks let me tell you something I
have recently found out and I've never
drunk from Starbucks I'm going to give
you guys two ingredients for those who
like coconut milk and for those who
don't yeah there is a coffee brand and
I'm going to give you my wife's recipe
cuz from now on I don't drink from
anywhere and there is another place that
I used to drink from which we're going
to also visit brothers and sisters if
you and to you it is more important that
your Starbucks coffee that tast so
amazing is more important than the blood
of the brothers and sisters who have
been spilled in Gaza as we speak 20,000
people I'm going to be starting this
boycott movement I'm not going to stop
every month keep an eye on my channel
I'll be mentioning two to three products
where I will be visiting their stores
and I'm going to step it up a notch it's
not just going to be me me sitting down
I'm going to have the pictures of the
dead bodies of the Palestinian babies
and I'm going to stick it on these
stores wherever they are Adidas pumar
wherever it is I am coming for you guys
legally one by one boycot Works carry on
boycotting it and before that boycott
your sins boycott your wrongdoings
brothers and sisters Allah's Right comes
above anyone's if you're not praying
your Salah pray your Salah make Dua for
our Palestinian brothers and sisters
carry on sharing the post inshallah and
don't forget boycott these products and
donate inshallah in the link where we
are buying an organization walk forever
is a registered charity who is buying a
building in Wales to fund and help the
people in Gaza not by just building not
just by food but also legally to help
inshallah Palestine become free where we
can see the Jews the Christians the
Muslims and even be it those Zionist who
live in peace together like they did
before till then the blood of your
brothers and sisters in this in this
coffee next time you go to Starbucks
shame on you that if you are more
concerned about the flavors of what you
taste and your
comfort the of the till the day I die
inshallah I remember my daughter 7 years
old 2 years old and a f Monon year old
baby I have three daughters and every
time I look at them I imagine those
bodies of our brothers and sisters if
you don't have an atom weight of Shame
go and buy from Starbucks that's all I'm
going to say inshallah and boycott them
and just a quick disclaimer we was
watching Pierce Morgan's debate with
hijab some brothers ordered pizza and
they sent free Coca-Cola and seven up we
anyone that knows us knows we will never
intentionally ever buy this product so
those who have a good cleaner and good
assumptions of us may Allah bless you
and those who think we are filippin have
nef like them to hell with you you carry
on supporting your governments or
whoever who's supporting Israel yes we
will condemn them and talk about them
till the day they die Starbucks to hell
yes boycott these son of a and that's
what I'm going to say and keep an eye as
I take you guys on a tour of all these
other products that are supporting
Israel one way or another 11 billion
pounds they lost let's make sure inshah
they shut down
everywhere